ladies and gentlemen we would like to
welcome you
to guantanamo we're arriving at the home
of the most
costly and controversial prison on earth
for more than a century this corner of
cuba has been an american naval base but
for the past
20 years it's been notorious for the
guantanamo bay detention center
now overgrown with weeds and vines this
is the site of the old camp x-ray
when the first prisoners arrived here in
2002
they were held in eight square foot
cages force-fed
beaten and tortured that image of men in
orange suits
shackled kneeling on the ground in the
oppressive
cuban heat is the enduring one for many
across the world of guantanamo bay
detention center
around 780 suspected terrorists have
been held at guantanamo
just eight have been convicted and four
have had those convictions
overturned 39 prisoners now remain
held at a detention center which we're
not allowed to film
hearings take place not on american soil
but under a military judge at camp
justice
we're here for one of them abdul hadiala
raki is charged with being an al-qaeda
commander in afghanistan
allegedly responsible for multiple
deaths
his defense lawyer believes he's a
prisoner of war and should be
repatriated
this case is essentially the litigation
of the war in afghanistan
and the war in afghanistan is over
president biden told us that last week
the united states entered into a peace
agreement with the taliban
a year and a half ago and certainly at
this point
guantanamo bay shouldn't be the only
place that the war in afghanistan is
being fought
my client should be sent home abdul hadi
al-iraqi has been in guantanamo for 14
years
and his trial still hasn't properly
started yet
his case typifies why some say the
justice process here
isn't fit for purpose every prisoner at
guantanamo bay costs around 10 million
pounds a year
former president obama tried and failed
to shut it down
now it's president biden's problem this
former guantanamo prosecutor has
switched sides
fundamentally it was wrong to
take people and place them in a cage and
throw away the key
if there was ever a true intent to
follow through with meaningful fair
trials
then that needed to happen quickly for
the 5500 people living in guantanamo
it's more than a prison camp and that's
certainly the message the new boss of
the naval base wants to convey
with the war in afghanistan winding down
is guantanamo moving to a new chapter
yes of course uh we this installation
has been
in existence for over 100 years the
exposure that received
based on the detention facility is
understandable
but it's not the sole function of this
installation
[Music]
the detention center here was
established to bring justice
in wake of the horrors of 9 11. 20 years
on it's yet to be delivered
and as the forever wars are ending the
last vestige of that conflict limps on
martha kellner sky news guantanamo bay
you